I’m ranking EVERY FIRE USER IN ANIME from
~~~~crazy fire-breathing girlfriends like
this to characters with such powerful
fire that they might as well be gods.
And in a bit of a twist right out of the gate, I’m
going to put the captain commander Yamamoto from
Bleach in the God Tier right away because
he is one of the absolute strongest fire
user in all of anime. I mean his fire is
literally as hot as the core of the sun,
which is pretty god-like if you ask me. But to
keep the surprises coming, I’m actually going
to show you exactly how many characters are as
strong or maybe even stronger than Yamamoto in
the God Tier. Including him, there are ten of
these absolute fire wielding powerhouses who I
think are clearly above every other fire user
in all of anime. Now who are these characters?
Well, they are all extraordinary fire users,
but first let’s shift down from the
God tier to the next strongest tier,
which is the Dust Tier. Now I'll admit this is
s bit of a strange name, but basically, to be in
this tier your flames have to be SO INCREDIBLY
STRONG that they can literally turn an enemy
into a pile of ash. And what better character to
start this tier than Genos from One Punch Man,
whose incineration Cannons can literally
obliterate opponents and leave nothing behind.
Now we might as well continue introducing the
tiers, so next up is the Generic Overpowered
Anime Fire Users tier. Whew, that's a mouthful.
Maybe I should have just called it the Generic
Tier after all. And starting off this tier
we have Magna Swing from Black Clover,
who like most of the characters in this tier
can basically summon fire and toss it around to
attack his opponents. Not the most powerful, but
still decently strong enough for his own story.
But Magna Swing might as well be a god compared
to this next tier, which is the Poooffff Tier.
And essentially these are fairly weak fire users,
at least compared to the rest of the characters
in this video. To start it off we are going to
go way back in the history of anime to Sailor
Moon. And this truly was one of the OG shows,
at least outside of Japan, and Sailor Mars is
the fire using princess, buuuutttt if I'm being
honest she’s pretty weak. I mean her strongest
attack is Flame Sniper, but even this move isn’t
powerful enough to take out a strong opponent.
Which is crazy that Sailor Mars
is even above this final tier,
which I’ll call the ‘Barely-Counts-as
A-Fire-User’ Tier. And the perfect example
of this is Bols from Akame Ga Kill. So while
Bols is surprisingly a pretty nice person,
he has done some truly horrible things such
as incinerating entire villages with his super
powered flamethrower. But since he can’t actually
make fire himself, he falls into this bottom tier.
Which brings us to what might be the most
controversial ranking in this entire video.
That’s because we are going to put Madara from
Naruto riiiiggghhht… her. Now before every single
Madara fan types angrily in the comments below,
one thing to keep in mind is that I am ranking
these characters most based on their fire powers,
not necessarily all of a character’s overpowered
abilities. And while Madara is certainly a
God Tier fighter, his strongest fire attack,
Ultimate Fire Release, is a wide ranging attack
that ultimately was able to be fairly easily
blocked by many ninjas, so that drops him down
from God to Dust Tier, at least as a fire user.
But while the master ninja can burst out
in flames, this next character is a literal
fire breathing monster. Of course I’m talking
about Charizard from Pokemon whose Mega X and Y
transformations make him one of the more powerful
mons in all of Pokemon. Plus, he’s just a personal
favorite of mine, so don’t complain that these
transformations aren’t in the anime. This is my
tier list. I can do what I want. Bam. Dust Tier.
Even though they did make him into a fluffy toy.
Do you know who also needs a hug? This guy
right here, Escanor from the Seven Deadly Sins,
who is also the second of our God
Tiers. Because during the night he
becomes a whiny weakling who could sure
use some support, but during high noon,
oh boy. This man becomes the literal Sun God,
whose blazing sun powers can make even the
Demon King look like some kind of slime-tier
character. Mr. The One is God Tier for sure.
But even he would run like crazy
from Kyoko Kirisaki from Black Cat,
who is so crazy she is going to invent
a brand new tier. This is the Crazy Fire
Breathing Girlfriend tier. And Kirisaki definitely
deserves to be here because she prefers to defeat
her opponents by kissing them and then burning
them from the inside. Yeesh. Swipe Left for me.
And while Kirisaki might freak you out,
at least she can’t literally burn your soul
like Rei Ogami from Code Breaker. In fact,
his flames are so strong that turning someone
to ash is easy, and his most powerful attack
can burn an enemy's soul so that they can
never commit another crime in their entire
life. Which earns a place in Dust Tier, and my
vote for him to become police chief for sure.
Which might make this next ranking a bit
controversial, because Hiei from Yuyu
Hakusho uses his Dark Flames to become
our next God-Tier level fire user. And
you may not know that these evil looking
flames can destroy anything in their path,
including people and buildings. And while that
is similar to Ogami who we just put in Dust Tier,
to me Hiei's flames are just on such another level
altogether that I have to rank him in God Tier.
But that’s three God Tier fire characters
already and we still have seven left to go,
plus a ton of other characters. Have
we ranked your favorite fire user yet?
So let’s knock out some of the lower tier
characters. First is Bakugo from My Hero
Academia. And while his explosions
are pretty powerful, they only earn
him a place in the Generic tier because as
usual, he gets the side-character treatment.
And I hate to say it, but I’m also going to
put his classmate Shoto Todoroki in this tier
as well. Which I think is pretty fair, because
I mean he can only truly unlock his strongest
fire if he balances it with his ice powers.
Plus as we’ve seen recently in the manga,
he couldn’t even 100% take out another of the fire
users that we will see later on in the ranking.
Now to ruffle even more feathers, let’s discuss
Ace and Sabo from One Piece. Because they both
have the same fire devil fruit powers, but
I’m going to rank one higher than the other.
Let’s start with Ace who unlike other
characters on this list is literally made
of fire. That means normal attacks just
pass right through him and he can summon
huge amounts of fire to create super
powerful attacks. So because of this,
and maybe a little bit of personal bias,
I’m going to put him in… Dust Tier. Yeah,
did you think I was going for God Tier? No, even
I have to be somewhat honest in these rankings.
But that leaves us with Sabo. And the big
question is does he go above OR below Ace? Well,
in my opinion, reusing the same powers
as Ace is not as impressive to me,
so even though Sabo is arguably stronger
because of his other fighting abilities,
I’m going to rank him down
in the Generic tier for now.
Now I’ll be honest, this next character was
going to be right beside Sabo in Generic Tier,
and that’s because Phoenix Ikki’s
powers are pretty standard. Fiery
blasts. Fire Punches. We know the deal.
But then I remembered two things. First,
this anime came out over thirty-five years ago,
which is before I was even born. Which means that
we have to ask ourselves if we can really
call these powers generic if Ikki was one
of the first mainstream characters to use them.
Plus, because he has the powers of the Phoenix,
every time he dies he comes back to life even
stronger. So good luck ever killing him. and
all this means I have no other choice but to
make him our fourth God Tier level character.
Now Nezuko from Demon Slayer is another character
I went back and forth about. On one hand,
her blood based fire powers have honestly
never really defeated anyone on their own.
They are more support powers to help her
brother. Plus they only affect demons,
so at first I was thinking of the Poof Tier,
but because her powers are pretty unique and
can deal some serious damage to even strong
demons, I bumped her up to the Generic Tier.
Now this next character showing up on
this tier list might shock you a bit,
and that’s because Levy from Black Lagoon
isn’t really a fire user. She actually
just uses guns and explosives - very well, I
might add - buuuttt, this is a fire tier list,
and there’s more than one kind of
fire, if you know what I mean. So
we’ll make her own special tier called the
Technically Not Fire But Still Fire tier.
And another character whose fire you
definitely don’t want to mess with
is my super powered kitty, Gojo,
whose fire blasts will surely take
over the world unless you stop him by
pressing that big red subscribe button.
Next in the Dust tier is possibly the
most popular character on this list,
Roy Mustang. The Flame Alchemist has an
unbelievable knowledge of fire alchemy,
so much so that with a single snap of his fingers,
he can create super accurate and destructive fire
blasts. The only thing actually holding him back
from God Tier is that his powers are harder to
use in the rain, although technically he can
separate the water molecules and light the
oxygen on fire by using a complex reaction
using… *continue mumbling scientifically*
Oh, right. Sorry. Back to the tier list.
While Mustang is a fire genius, Ayano
Kannagi from Kaze no Stigma can barely
control her magical Crimson Flame,
which lands her in the Poof Tier.
Now if you are an avid anime watcher, you
might have noticed there are characters from
one particular anime that we haven’t ranked
yet. Of course, I'm talking about Fire Force,
which is a show literally all about fire and
we could probably put almost every character
in Fire Force on this list. But that would
take way too long, so instead we are going
to name just a few of them. And what better way
to start than with our fifth God Tier character,
Leonard Burns. Seriously, this man’s power
levels can get off the charts. His ability
is called Voltage Nova, which basically
lets him continuously heat up his body,
giving him a huge buff in physical strength and
durability the longer it stays active. He brushes
off explosions with ease and can literally
melt fireproof clothing just by walking by.
But now there are only five God Tiers
left. Do you think you know who they are?
But even Burns’ doesn’t get as crazy as
these next three characters. That’s because
I’m dropping ANOTHER special tier called
the Pyromaniacs for those fire users who
are just a bit messed up in the head. And I
just had to keep them together in the script,
because leaving them alone could lead
to them setting the whole thing on fire.
The first is the fire/lightning
princess Azula from Avatar,
who shoots off lightning blasts
like a kid at a carnival game.
Right next to her is Dabi from My Hero Academia,
who has burned himself so much that he had to
replace his own skin. He is completely unhinged,
which you would especially know if you’ve
read the recent events in the manga.
And the final member of this Pyromaniacs tier
is Miyagawa from Mob Psycho, who has pretty
standard fire powers but is just an evil dude
who likes to watch his enemies burn to a crisp.
Luckily for us, the person who defeated Miyagawa
is up next, and that is Teruki Hanazawa,
also from Mob Psycho. However, Teru is a
man of many talents and for him, fire is
basically a side hustle since he can also use a
ton of other psychic abilities like forcefields,
explosions, air whips, and more, but if
we’re talking about just his fire powers,
he is pretty average, so he’s
going in the Generic Tier.
For example, Teruki would stand no
chance against this next character,
and that’s because Gabimaru from Hell’s Paradise
is an explosive flame-erupting ninja who can
burn his enemies to a crisp. And while you
might say his powers aren’t anything special,
I just love the fact that his powers are so
OP that when he is close to dying he unlocks
a fiery berserk mode that can even damage
gods. Definitely deserving of Dust Tier.
This next character takes that to an even higher
level. Unveiling the sixth God tier fire user,
we have Feitan from Hunter x Hunter. Because
even though he isn’t a pure fire user,
his ultimate attack turns all of the damage
he has taken into a blistering rising sun
that literally destroyed an entire fortress. And
that by itself deserves God Tier in my opinion.
However, one character you didn’t quite
make God Tier was Alibaba from Magi, whose
impressive-looking Flame Minister’s Beheading
Sword is pretty remarkable and can easily take
out weaker enemies, but just didn’t do enough
for me to put him any higher than Dust Tier.
The same can be said for Jogo from Jujutsu
Kaisen, who has some pretty incredible feats.
He can create a volcanic dimension and
his strongest attack from the manga can
bring down a massive flaming meteor that
can destroy an entire city block. Which
might have earned him God Tier except for
what happened against this next character.
And a brief manga spoiler warning here, but
when Jogo fought Sukuna the Cursed spirit
was defeated by this. Which I mean, what is
this? Sukuna’s not supposed to be able to use
fire! So where the heck do we rank this guy?
God Tier? Barely counts tier? I don’t know,
so let’s just make his own We Don’t Know WTF
This Is Tier. I’m allowed to do that, right?
Now, we’ve been dealing with some intense flames
for quite a while, so let’s simmer down a bit with
Hellfire Flame from One Punch Man in the Poof
Tier. This sword-wielding monster can kick and
slash with flames, so if you’re into fiery
swordsmen you might want to check him out.
And below him is Hao Asakura from Shaman King.
And even though Asakura is basically the most
powerful character in the whole show, he
is only so powerful because he fights by
summoning elemental spirits to fight for him
which is why he is in the Barely Counts tier.
But no one can say that this next
character doesn't fight on his own,
and his fire powers are like no one
else’s on this list. This is Shishio
Makoto from the legendary samurai anime Rurouni
Kenshin. This dude is an incredible swordsman,
but his flame powers actually come from a pretty
horrifying source. You see, Makoto soaked his
sword in the oily fat of countless opponents so
that now his sword can catch on fire whenever
he wants. That's pretty awful if you ask me,
but still cool to watch him duel with Kenshin.
If swords aren’t your thing though, how
about a giant fire breathing dog? Well,
that is exactly what we get with Pluto from Black
Butler. And while he certainly isn’t generic,
I don’t think he is extremely powerful
either, so he’s going in the Poof tier.
Now this leads us to probably the single
most Generic fire user in this ranking,
which is Mikoto Suoh from the K anime. Yeah,
that’s right. The show is literally just
called K. And he can basically use his aura
to create heat blasts and probably even help
him keep that sulky glare on his face 24/7.
Which is basically the same expression we
get from our seventh God Tier character,
Sasuke from Naruto. And as you can see we are
clearly ranking him above Madara, which may
trigger the Naruto fans here, but in my opinion,
he has such a master of his special Amaterasu
Flames, that he just had to be in God Tier. These
unique flames will only burn what Sasuke wants,
but if he truly lets them loose, they won’t stop
burning until there is nothing left of his enemy.
And while they didn’t really work on Madara,
they are super OP against basically anyone else.
This means if Sasuke is God Tier then his
brother Itachi must be… Dust Tier? Man,
the Naruto fan base is going to go insane. But
kinda using the same logic as with Sabo and Ace,
both of the brothers' strongest flames
are Amaterasu, but since Sasuke uses
them better than his brother, I just
have to rank Itachi one tier below.
ow if you’re feeling bad for
Itachi, maybe we should plop
him down with Kirisaki in the Crazy Fire
Girlfriend tier to cheer him up. No? Okay,
well we do have another addition to this tier
and that is Kotori Itsuke from Date a Live,
who is basically a fire spirit. But not just any
fire spirit because she can transform her arm
into a flaming ax or even an overpowered
flame cannon, because I mean why not…
And Megumin from Konosuba is another fire powered
girl, but she ends up in the Poof tier because
her fire spells quickly drain her Mana power which
leaves her relying on her allies most of the time.
And you'll never believe that
our next God Tier character was
a contender for the strongest fire user
ever. This is Benimaru from Fire Force,
whose Crimson Moon attack against this Fire
Demon literally took my breath away. I mean,
wow, what a super impressive power for one
of the strongest fire users in the story.
Now we’ve only got two God Tiers
left to go. And I'll just warn you,
they might be even stronger than Benimaru.
Before we get to those top dogs though,
we have Rin Okumura from Blue Exorcist,
who uses his supernatural blue fire and sword
skills to wipe out the royalty of the demon
world. However, perhaps his most impressive feat
is that he created a fire attack powerful enough
to take out the Impure King demon all while
leaving his friends untouched by the magical
blue flames. Pretty impressive if you ask me,
which lands him a solid spot in the Dust Tier.
Yet another character with Blue flames that we
are putting in Dust Tier is Starjun from Toriko.
This master chef and Gourmet Hunter can create
flames hot enough to melt Toriko’s iron silverware
attacks, and even produce giant flame slashes
that can create massive holes in the earth.
While Rin and Starjun’s blue
flames are awesome to look at,
this next character’s fire is some of the
prettiest in all of anime. This is Julis
Riessfeld from Asterisk War who summons fire with
the imagery of flowers. Quite nice if you ask me,
but good looks only get you so far in this
ranking, so down in Poof tier she goes.
Which brings us to Tasuki from the anime Fushigi
Yuugi, who is honestly a pretty powerful fighter,
except that all of his fire power comes from his
magical Tessen fan. Barely Counts tier for him.
Now if you want yet another OG
anime that will blow your mind,
then check out Recca Hanabishi from
the Flame of Recca. And Recca fully
earns his place in the Dust tier because he
can summon fire at will, with his strongest
attacks using the power of seven mythical
fire dragons to demolish his enemies.
However, you cannot talk about classic anime
without mentioning Jojo’s Bizarre Adventure, which
of course has its very own fire user, Mohammed
Avdol, whose Stand power is called Magician Red,
which fights with fire . And I honestly had a
bit of trouble ranking him. He’s certainly not
Dust level, but I think he would wipe out all of
Poof tier, so even though it hurts my very soul
to call anyone from Jojo’s generic, I’m going
to drop him into the Generic Overpowered Tier.
Which is a better spot than Stella Vermillion from
Chivalry of a Failed Knight earned, because her
fiery sword skills are not all that impressive,
especially because it took her basically the
whole anime to figure out that she had dragon
powers. That's a Poof tier if I’ve ever seen one.
Though if you want a character who is a master of
his powers right from the very start of the show,
you should check out Stiyl Magnus from A
Certain Magical Index. This Generic tier
chain smoking pyromancer can summon fire with
his magical runes and spells, and if he needs to
bust out a strong attack he can create a fiery
monster to help fight against his opponents.
But he’s not actually a good guy, which
can also be said about Endeavor from My
Hero Academia as well because of the way
he seriously traumatized his kids. However,
Endeavor is certainly an absolute powerhouse
of a fighter, whose Prominence Burn attack
can vaporize opponents in an instant.
Which earns him a place in Dust Tier.
If you want the perfect person to beat some
responsibility into Endeavor, look no further
than Mereoleoona Vermillion from Black Clover.
This noblewoman magician is the captain of a Royal
Knight squad and fights with giant explosive fire
blasts which makes her the strongest fire user
in the story and she can certainly compete with
nearly everyone else on this list. And she nearly
made it into God Tier, but couldn’t quite crack
my top ten, so she’ll have to stay in Dust Tier.
However, the next character to ascend to
Godhood is Natsu from Fairy Tail. Because
even though he can get stomped on by other
elements, there are almost no fire users as
strong as this fire eating monster of a
character, whose flames are so powerful
that he can melt stone just by walking
past and even take out monstrous dragons.
Which leaves only one more God Tier character
left, and if you’ve been wondering all this
time if I was going to leave Shinra off another
list, well then this one's for you. Because the
main character of Fire Force has gotten so
strong that his fire can even allow him to
zip around at light speed and destroy opponents
with truly massive explosions. And those are
just a few of the god-like abilities
that he unlocks later on in the manga.
But sadly we cannot end on the fiery godliness
of Shirna because we have one more character to
go. And that is the Flame Hashira Rengoku
from Demon Slayer. Now this may come as a
shock to some of you but Rengoku is actually
not a fire user. While there was some debate
about the incredible fire powers that we
see in the anime, these flames are not real,
they are just a visualization of
the sword skills. But they do look
so cool so we’ll throw him in with the Levy in
the Technically Not Fire But Still Fire tier.
Buuuttt, while the Hashira’s elemental powers
are fake, the demons’ magical abilities in the
show are very much real. So can you imagine
if Rengoku was a demon and had actual fire
powers? Surely he would become one of
the strongest demons alive, right? Well,
if you want to find out how that would go,
you can check out this video right here.
Thanks for watching, and
I’ll see you in the next one.